did you see that report that came out
this week listing people who talk and
Converse and behave like us as National
Security
threats yeah oh that was the thing about
the manow swamp yeah yes yeah literally
the there's a guy running for congress
in New Jersey who was convinced that you
know the the last half an hour of us
talking is the equivalent of the Taliban
and
Isis there's there's something to say
here because uh some other people have
War
CL CLS Clan masks on shows and um once
you get to see some of the reactions of
the kids that they meet yeah uh where
they
say [__] are trash or I don't know
something like that to that effect I
mean there's a real negative influence
on some people and I'm not sure these uh
people talking influencers whatever you
want to call them um really realize what
the effect is to its full
extent I'm not saying there was that
clip of
um the [__] that guy's name sneo and
there was kids around him and they were
saying like disparaging negative things
about women in the airport yeah all that
stuff that's that's where like these
guys do some weird stuff like the manow
swamp gets a bad rap it has a bad PR
issue for a reason now promoting
positive masculinity strength virtues
all that sort of stuff
they're still going to have an issue
with that too but but I think what the
problem is is there's not a lot of good
men that are good at being men in the
manow swamp again one of the reasons why
I don't associate with them anymore um
and they're going to amplify that right
like they're going to take something
like that and they're going to turn it
up to 17 and they're going to make a big
deal out of it they're going to get
government funding they're going to try
to redirect traffic you know which they
talked about you know in that article um
50 I don't know if you can link it in
the private chat and I'll put it in the
live chat if anybody wants to look at it
do you know what that thing was called
uh I God if I forget I forget now but it
was literally they were identifying
prominent members of the Mana swamp and
and just saying all the content was the
equivalent of you know domestic
terrorism guy yeah there was a guy who
used to work for the state department
he's running for congress in New Jersey
and he's got saw written all over him
and again you know as we we've said a
million times on here weak men are the
most dangerous men and this guyute was
that it I don't know he he he he looks
like you know your average Suburban saw
Dad he's running for congress and he's
Lally labeled like our chatter here
might as well be the equivalent of Isis
chatter to him hang on it was a brand
new news piece let me try to pull it up
gra implications of terroris I think
this is it but I mean great replacement
in the man isphere implications of
terrorism like um yeah he was at the
state department and he compiled all of
this and he was he was counter terrorism
yeah and he he came up with this but I
don't I don't I don't completely blame
them there's some real stupid [__] that
those [__] idiots say over and over
again and dude they're not good people
they're not no you know we had a
campfire campfire chat and we're like
literally why would you go these guys
pray on they kind of pray on weak guys
who can't get girls and they're like
join you know join me and you'll be
dripping in hoes yeah and you you you
could probably teach them everything
they need to know in about 20 minutes
and yeah they do they they go off all
[__] crap and as as as I think I
said last week or in one of our group
chats if you want to learn to become a
pickup artist it's like getting someone
who can drive to finance and purchase a
vehicle you know yeah so I did a Google
search on manosphere terrorists you know
those two keywords and then I hit news
and there's one two three there's three
articles in the last two weeks um
so like anybody in that space I mean I
said this years ago I said stupid name
for the group sounds like a gay
nightclub manosphere um losers in the
group that you wouldn't want to have sit
down at a table with your family or your
kids uh with some with skeletons in
their closet some with entire [__]
graveyards um there you know
bad people like some decent information
but bad people I mean I've I've already
aggregated and organize all the
information in a very easy to consumable
way in my book I mean you can get
everything you need 90% of what you need
to know like out of my book The
unplugged Alpha but just some real
losers and you know they're going to
get you know like you saw seen what's
happened in the last couple weeks I mean
who's had trouble in the manow swamp um
just pearly things got either
deplatformed or demonetized fresh and
fit who
else they named Rolo in that article you
know the Godfather I mean you know you
go around calling yourself The Godfather
putting on Godfather costumes and [__]
you know they're going to come for you
you
know
yeah anybody anybody that they see as
Downstream of the Tate Brothers is a
target essentially anything yeah and and
again it's a bunch of weak men who are
going after you know I mean since I
started consuming your content in 2015
and since I joined the community it's
been like maybe 20% of our discussions
have been about women and the rest is
like just look what MAF is doing
dropping weight look what the other guys
are doing this guys bouncing business
ideas it's been literally nothing to do
with the with the core of the Mana swamp
which is a bunch of guys that can't get
girls uh getting advice from a bunch of
other guys on how to get girls I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out